one star food here sucks line way too
long
[Music]
hi everyone I'm heaven I'm Tracy and
welcome to another round of heaven and
Tracy is this real life as a segment
where we question reality collectively
it is for situations where you're like
did I read that right am I in the
correct universe the right timeline
randomly I was googling the Great Wall
of China because I was amazed by it
what's going on and I noticed it says
1897 reviews averaged 4.4 so I was like
what do you mean who rated the Great
Wall of China so that like the small
description google goods is ancient
world wonder that wins for more than
5,000 miles across china with towers and
walkways so yeah
ancient world wonder i mean already and
let me just review a snippet of three
stars my child almost fell over some
stupid people running so I wouldn't
recommend the dot-dot-dot but the food
was awesome smiley face it was okay but
the walking great oh it was like you
know what I'm walking too much I did not
anticipate this great one star
I had a all-caps amazing time in China
the Great Wall of China was my favorite
thing that I saw awesome all caps he was
awesome
the view was terrible and I almost fell
off watch was fun I did not have that
for the record
overall I would rate it 1 out of 5 that
is 20% I am a math major two stars
the Great Wall of China is too damaged
when it's fixed I will come again he was
not impressed
few stars it was okay the service was
terrible and the walk was a bit rocky
and too long for my liking some good
sites but the stuff but the staff was
rude and didn't speak English too wrong
in this review so you barely speak
English five stars
a real place to go when you're waiting
for your husband to finish up his octave
rehab I went to look to her profile to
see if there is more but there wasn't
I'm just so curious about her life she
they were going through it she's like
you know I let me hit up the Great Wall
time one star why is there opening times
it's so long hey gonna close the wall oh
you don't close the wall I would love to
me just read reviews of historical
landmarks like ours
oh man Tracy let's do me a never ending
segment have so many of those excited
and really sad